aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par l'historien pascal ory et
grâce à son travail
on va comprendre pourquoi elle symbolise
une turquie qui a voulu s'occidentaliser
à marche forcée à travers moustapha
kemal et son entourage
[Musique]
c'est une image sale flou et plein de
grains pour à croire que c'est une image
volée quand on examine le cadrage
d'autant plus qu'on en connaît même pas
l'auteur cette photo choisie par pascal
ory a été prise le 27 août 1934 et
représente deux danseurs à droite le
fondateur de la turquie moderne mustafa
kemal il alors à l'apogée de sa carrière
de chef de l'état qui durera 15 ans et
trois mois après cette photographie il
se voit même conféré le titre d'atatürk
père des turcs par l'assemblée nationale
turque et à gauche a fait tinhan l'une
de ses neuf filles adoptives une jeune
institutrice qui l'a rencontré à izmir
et qui l'envoyaient en 1925 en suisse
apprendre le français et parfaire son
éducation
il procède de manière similaire avec ses
huit autres filles adoptives érigé en
modèle de la nouvelle femme turque
l'une d'entre elles c'est bien à gauche
chaîne deviendra même la première femme
pilote de chasse dès que kemal devient
chef de l'état il impose dans les
réceptions officielles le smoking aux
hommes la robe de soirée aux femmes et
le tango pour tout le monde
l'année où moustapha kemal danse tout en
gouaille a fait tinhan les radios turc
reçoit l'ordre de ne plus rien diffuser
d'autres que des musiques occidentales
ce que nous fait remarquer pascal ory
c'est que ce n'est pas un simple caprice
de dictateur mais l'une des décisions
qu'il prend comme disciple du mouvement
jeunes turcs pour occidentalisée à
marche forcée
l'ancien empire ottoman il a pris de
nombreuses décisions comme l'imposition
de l'alphabet et du calendrier latin
l'instauration officielle de la laïcité
ou encore l'interdiction du voile dans
l'espace public quant à fait
elle devient professeur à l'université
d'ankara la capitale de la nouvelle
nation
elle est entre autres l'auteur de deux
études qui disent tout l'une sur les
caractères anthropologique des
populations de la turquie et l'autre sur
l'émancipation de la femme turque
pour pascal ory il y a deux catégories
d'image sous le regard de l'historien
certaines sondes anglais revêtus par la
société d'une fonction a indexé sur leur
efficacité supposé fonctions religieuses
ou artistiques politiques ou économiques
ce sont des icônes mais les autres
images n'ont à priori dans leur
affichage aucune de ces qualités là
ce sont au sens strict des images sans
qualités elle en acquiert une co prix
d'un commentaire cette photographie
qu'on a vus ensemble appartient
clairement à cette seconde catégorie
merci à pascal ory qui nous a permis de
faire cette vidéo et à bientôt pour une
nouvelle image sur une image une
histoire
[Musique]